perform a sequence of transformations to
try to map the movable figure that's
this figure right over here onto
c-o-r-a-l or coral so c-o-r-a-l
is this polygon right over here and then
we have to figure out are these two
figures congruent so they're congruent
if through some combination of
translations rotations and reflections i
can make this figure sit right on top of
figure c-o-r-a-l
so let's use this tool right over here
to do that to do some translations
rotations and reflections
and so the first thing i want to do let
me translate it so they get close to
each other and maybe i can get a one let
me let me see if i can get one point in
common
so just like that
i've been able to get this point in
common it seems like if these are going
to be congruent that those would
correspond to each other
and now it looks pretty clear that these
are reflections of each other so let me
reflect let me reflect them along
so it looks like if i were to put my
point right there and let's see if i
reflect right along
go right in between looks like if i
reflect right along that which i might
end up being done
and i am done so just with that little
literal translation followed by
reflection i was able to make these two
figures sit on top of each other so
these are definitely so these are
definitely congruent